all right Jonathan yo Jonathan where'd
you grow up where you from originally
Los Angeles Watts area tell me about
your family growing up my family growing
up they was always like on drug
dysfunctional they loved us but um you
know sometimes they um got carried away
with with drug addiction and growing up
it was like I was grew up by the streets
everything I learned like basically I
learned from the streets you my parents
didn't really care about me so I grew up
going through our life without um
knowing exactly what I had to do you
know and nobody told me nothing so I
thought everything I did was cool
until I start hanging on the wrong
people and then I got I joined the gang
and then that got worse my drug Hab
became worse and then I just started
losing focus of my my life how do you
describe your childhood in general
bad dysfunctional do you have any good
Role
Models the model the role models I had
were they were not a good role model
they were like bad people like me like I
trying to I was looking up to people in
the gang people in the gangs and Thugs
and pimps and stuff like that you know
like I didn't have no real like broke my
like a a uncle or a parent or somebody
that's doing good or nothing like that
you know even I'm not saying that my
people are bad people but everybody has
their downfall you know and it seemed
like they got a little too carried away
with the drugs and the addiction and
they they really didn't tell me much so
I didn't saw I live my life just on my
own basically you joined the gang did
they come with some uh prison time yeah
I did 10 years in the prison I just got
out 10 years for what for attempted
murder really yeah I just I just paroled
on
20120 are you still active in the game
yeah yeah but it's a different type of
active like of course I I ain't no no
weird [__] or no person that
told or nothing like that you know or no
PC like I'm still straight in there and
I here just active I'm not like as far
as active in the gang I'm I still am but
not like going around gang banging on
people putting that first before
anything you know like now I conduct
myself a little different but I don't
deny where I'm from or anything like
that you know or I still I still go hang
around there but like it's not like
before I got to go do stuff and now I
could just chill in the way but that's
like that lifestyle is kind of [__]
too though yeah yeah you regret getting
yeah yeah I wish I would U deal with my
sister and other people there you know
go to school and um do right do the
right thing your sister's living a she's
doing good now yeah yeah she got she got
kids and got married and it changed her
whole life how old are you now I'm 31
31 you like to go to figuroa Street
sometimes yeah yeah yeah sometimes yeah
how often will you go down there like
every Proby like twice a week what do
you do for work or Landscaping I like
cut grass and trim trees and do stuff
like that but um my paycheck I don't
know I be using losing it to the wrong
place eat up a lot of your paychecks
spend girls down there yeah girls and
drugs in the room and all that stuff but
it's cool my job drugs are still a part
of your life yeah yeah and the girls on
fig and drugs probably go hand inand
right yeah it's easier like it's more
it's more convenient for more it's more
convenient for um than dealing with your
girlfriend or your wife or stuff like
that you know like you just pay for your
do you prefer those kind of
relationships to the sometimes yeah
sometimes to a girl that you would meet
that doesn't work the street yeah yeah
yeah because they're more cooler like
they Ain really tripping and you got a
girlfriend I really never had a
girlfriend like that I was always been
in jail you know but I messed around
with different females but it's always
like they always they too
needy they got too many um expectations
and stuff like that the girls on fig
They Don't
Really hid and by you know they come
when they come and that's it do you have
regulars that you go to huh do you have
regulars that you'll go to yeah yeah
yeah like two of
them you like the black girls white
girls Mexican girls black girl Mexican
girls any girl actually any woman anyone
really yeah but I I like black girls too
Mexicans other than that that's all I
really mess daed with you you ever get
hustled robbed yeah I've been robbed
before how' that happen I was too
carried away in the shower and taking
the shower and it let somebody ran out
my pants and my clothes and my keys and
everything but I still went back like a
dumb
ass and try to cover it up and made it
seem like it wasn't th but I ain't
stupid it took my keys my wallet my pant
everything so I been able to run after
them you know all that I
guess but yeah I ain't see no but I did
it
yet it's crazy how in the street life
there nothing there no joke it's
dangerous down there you hear about
people get murdered down there every
yeah raped murder stab Rob and it's like
why you going to rob somebody on fig you
know they they ain't got much especially
the females they be out there for trying
to make some money like why you going
people trying to rob them too I don't
understand y i i look after a couple of
like my peop you know couple of workers
on Fe like my I consider like my friend
or sister my play sister or whatever
you but yeah yeah friends yeah I got a
couple friends not that many but I got a
couple the 10 years you spent in prison
you feel like that set you back in terms
of your no I didn't set me back but um
it said it held me back from um and
living my life you know enjoying my 20s
or my childhood like that's held me back
from that but other than that cuz I
still like I still advance to
be coming from where I came from I'm um
I came to be still all right you know
I'm not doing that bad yeah your does
your prison record follow you or yeah
yeah yeah fighting for a job or whatever
yeah I kind of sucks I I got a couple
stabbings in prison so that kind of
messed right now having like like just
the Landscaping luckily my my my um my
boy he hook me up you know they
feelingly friendly so they give me a job
I don't I just cut grass and trim trees
and do people's edges so like it don't
really matter you know it's not that
much of a hard work you don't have
kids not that I
[Music]
know what are your dreams for the next 5
10 years next 5 10 years I'll be like
I'm 31 so like 35 40 I'm trying to just
be
stable you know me like stay out of
trying to avoid that as much proba but
just stay out like know that I ain't got
nothing no worries like far as probation
parole [__] like that you know I could
just chill at my house live my life and
just Ki
me you don't even got to be necessarily
with money just you know just um I want
peace and Tranquility you and just I
don't want too many people around me and
Sh if you had your life to live all over
again what what kind of things would you
have done differently well I would try
to be like like somebody really
um uhu I'm trying to be like somebody
really um how can I say that like
somebody in the world that we really
need like somebody like important like
like
doctor or judge or or something like
that you know law law
enforcement cuz now now I see
everything's bad and good you know did
you finish High School no I graduated in
in j a hall I would like I wouldn't mind
to be a
cop like that that [__] to me the cops
ain't bad people you know but they they
got their job or some are bad but you
can see yourself as a cop huh you can
see yourself as a cop I think I'll be a
tight ass cop yeah it's interesting to
to F line between a a thug or a hood and
you know a hood rat and and a cop oh
yeah big difference but yeah I can see
like both Sid like like but when I stay
it's a Metro League you know so it's
like they got Sheriff they got LAPD but
for real who wouldn't want to be a cop
man you got the you got the badge you
the law nobody can tell you nothing you
get away with a lot probably you
probably get away with a lot yeah a lot
of stress though too yeah you got to
worry about yeah that's true your lot
life on the beat probably ain't easy I
would to be like a fireman or something
some crazy [__] you know some I know my
when I could be Tire on and be
good get save my money get a little
retire life some little insurance going
on all my friends they're dead already
you know my my friend he just killed
himself the other day you know like shot
on accident but to me like you don't get
no gun just to me I think he probably he
was going through some stuff you know so
he took care of whatever he took care of
but pretty crazy man talking about he
was only like 15 years old I like try to
like race him I've been around him since
I got out pretty cool dude but he like
about two months ago he just shot
himself why do you think so many young
men end up in gangs down south central
cuz they got know where they one to feel
welcomed or or want to feel love that's
why I family than the family is yeah I
join the game cuz I used be like man man
nobody got my bag I ain't got nobody to
talk to like what's going on I see all
these dudes right here then they start
looking out for me give me money give me
clothes get a car so I just join the
gang to be um to feel
welcome or or or important but it wasn't
not what I thought it was the gang [__]
[__] it [__] you up back to the girls
on fig yeah girls on fig too that's I
got to beig people be addicted to that
stuff you're addicted to it yeah I'll be
over there when I get some money in my
pocket it' be hard to drive down fig and
see all those girls and once you open
that door it's and you can continue
pattern you keep on going and BEC
regular you think prostitution should be
legal yeah why not I think it should the
girls they choose to sell they they
choose to have just illegal to them for
them to have intercourse for whoever
they want if they want to do it um when
they get money from it financially why
not they they they tax us for everything
else the government not getting their
their tax out of it you know like
anything else like cigarettes weed you
know pretty sure if they legalize it
they probably would I'm pretty sure if
they legalize they probably will get
their little um cut out of it you as
long as they get their money you know
how they know how they work but yeah
there a lot of things out there man you
ever get attached to any of these girls
you've met yeah I got like one or one of
them I see her like like like my my like
my like close friend of
mine she always getting robed and stuff
so it's kind of like kind of [__] up I
Tred to like help her out but I could
help her out when she she continues to
go back with the same people that be
robbing her you know it's messed up my
mom my mom was kind of like messed up on
drugs too so I kind of like see I think
like man my mom and but
[__] yeah I got to stop going over there
probably move out of state or something
Jonathan what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life the most important lesson I learned
in my
life will be
on no matter what just keep it no matter
what happens to you in life you got to
keep going forward and don't let don't
let don't let that don't let your past
Define your
future another thing too like like when
you [__] up when you make a mistake own
up to it like don't try to beat around
the B I'm trying to have excuses cuz
I've gotten in trouble in prison before
like for drug Debs and I told the people
like my my my my people like he yeah
they asked me he you weard you a lot of
money right here like to other races and
all this you going to get in trouble and
I told them straight up like you know to
be honest with you I ain't going to lie
to you man like I do owe some money to
them but um it's not what they trying to
do trying to say you know but since you
as me I'm not going to lie to you but
yeah I know I shouldn't be like don't
take it like I'm just saying oh yeah I
don't give a [__] cuz that person was
really influential you he could have had
me hurt but he's like you know what D
you didn't lie to me man like you know
how many I've been locked up for 30
something years he said you the first
person that told me straight up like
yeah like everybody I've got gotten into
it or or inquired about this they lied
they beat on the bush they make a
[__] like you was the first person
that said yeah I do cuz and meaning to
that it's like oh you could probably get
really hurt for that [__] you know but
the hom was like okay since you since
you said yeah a friend like we're not
going trip on you like that you know but
he told me to always be up front don't
St what it is
that's all right Jonathan thank you so
much for sharing your story no problem
wish you lots of luck out there thanks
thank you very
much